as everybody knows Game of Thrones based
on the novels by the greatest fantasy
writer of our time george RR martin yes
now we we were really hoping George
could be here tonight but we were told
this is true that he couldn't come
because he's holed up at his house
working very hard on his latest book the
winds of winter so it can be turned into
new Game of Thrones episodes ok
now I'm a huge G ot fans out
[Music]
they'll never figure out what that means
and I really saved a lot of time it
really did my smirking afterwards cost
us 40 minutes now I'm a big fan and
along with everyone else I'm dying to
know how George is progressing with the
book so even though it's illegal here's
what I did I hacked into George RR
Martin's home security system I've been
recording him all week I haven't seen
the footage yet but I'm excited to see
how he's getting along with the book
let's check it out what's he was doing
looking looking at oh that's not a good
sign
that is not does not look productive
does not look productive
maybe he's I don't know oh for God's
sake that is no that's not helping in
any way get the book written there will
be no toy cars I hate thinking Andy he's
he Mike he might have an idea I think
he's thinking it yes I think he's got an
idea
george RR martin has an idea this oh
[Music]
hold on let's see what's he's gonna get
to work soon I know it is I really know
he's gonna get to work very soon where
is he
[Applause]
yeah
I was just fake told that he left his
house this morning oh so so I sent a
camera crew out to follow him I hope
he's working on the book I really do
let's check it out
okay he's thinking that's a good sign
he's outside thinking what's he
how is that he's up he's out and he's
down way too dizzy wait he said where is
he now oh he's buying oh my god another
our why how many doesn't man easy
what I just got word
I just got fake told that he's back at
the house maybe he's finally getting
down to work let's go live let's see
what he's up to
don't know where he
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography